JESSE WATTERS, JUDGE JEANINE
PIRRO, SHANNON BREAM,
GREG GUTFELD.
5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND THIS
IS "THE FIVE."
HELLO, CALLING AMERICA A RACIST
IS NOT ENOUGH.
THEY WERE INVITING THE REST OF
THE WORLD TO DO IT AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS WILTING
UNITED NATIONS EXPERTS TO FIGHT
INJUSTICE AND INEQUALITY.
SECRETARY OF STATE TONY BLINKEN
SAID IT IS TO CONFRONT THE
SCORCH OF RACISM, RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION AND XENOPHOBIA
HERE AT HOME AND AROUND THE
WORLD.
AND THE WHITE HOUSE IS ACTUALLY
BACKING HIM UP.
>> HE BELIEVES RESPONSIBLE
NATIONS MUST NOT SHRINK FROM
SCRUTINY OF HUMAN RIGHTS RECORD.
RATHER, THEY SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE
WITH INTENT TO IMPROVE IT AND
ALSO PUSH AND LISTEN UP AMP HOOD
AND SHINE A LIGHT ON OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT NEED TO DO
BETTER.
THAT IS THE ROLE WE ARE PLAYING
FOR THE UNITED STATES.
>> Jesse: KEEP IN MIND, THE
HUMAN RIGHTS COUNCIL THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WANTS TO CRITICIZE
AMERICA INCLUDES CUBA AND CHINA.
A QUICK REMINDER, KEEP IT RIGHT
NOW ROUNDING UP THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE FOR PROTESTING AGAINST
COMMUNISM.
THEY HAVE SHUT DOWN THE INTERNET
SO THE REST OF THE WORLD CAN'T
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IN CHINA, GROWING OVER A MILLION
UIGHURS IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
REPUBLICANS LIKE NIKKI HALEY ARE
CALLING ALL OF THIS JUST A BUNCH
OF NONSENSE.
>> YOU'VE GOT PEOPLE BEING
BULLIED AND BEATEN IN THE
STREETS OF CUBA.
YOU HAVE VENEZUELANS WHO ARE
ARRESTING POLITICAL PROTESTERS,
AND THE U.S. IS ASKING THE
UNITED NATIONS COME A CESSPOOL
TO COME INTO THE UNITED STATES D
INVESTIGATE US ON HUMAN
RIGHTS?
WE LOOK SO RIDICULOUS IN THE
EYES OF THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, LET'S
SAVE EVERYBODY THE TROUBLE.
THEY WILL CALL US RACIST, GREG.
>> Greg: I ALREADY HAVE THE
PREDICTION OF THE CONCLUSION
SYSTEMIC RACISM PERVADES
AMERICAN, INEQUALITY IN AMERICA
IS WORSE THAN EVER.
WHAT IS REALLY NEEDED IS
ANTIRACIST REEDUCATION PLAN AND
ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS.
I WAS WRONG ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
I SAID HE WAS THE LEAST UNIFYING
UNIFIER IN HISTORY.
HE IS UNIFYING US.
BECAUSE WE ARE ALL GETTING
REALLY, REALLY SICK OF BEING
TOLD WE ARE A BUNCH OF RACIST
GROUPS.
HE HAS GOTTEN TO THE POINT WHERE
HE IS ACTUALLY INVITING OUTSIDE
CONSULTANTS TO TELL US THAT WE
SUCK.
IT IS ALL PART OF HIS GREATER
PERNICIOUS ATTITUDE TOWARDS
AMERICA.
WE CAN NO LONGER THINK WE ARE
EXCEPTIONAL BECAUSE THAT IS
RACIST AND XENOPHOBIC.
EVEN PATRIOTISM STANDS OUT AS AN
ANOMALY.
THE FLAG IS RACIST, APPLE PIE IS
RACIST, WE HAVE SEEN THE
STORIES.
WE ARE NOW...
AMERICA LAST IS OUR PENANCE FOR
A MAN AMERICA FIRST APPEARANCE
OF THE TAXPAYER WILL BE PUNTING
A FOR THESE CORRUPT BUREAUCRATSE
BIGOTED AS WE DOUBLE PARK AND
ABUSE WORKERS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY DO.
>> Jesse: A REPORT ABOUT THAT,
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING IT.
LET'S SHOW WHY DO THIS?
THE COUNTRY DOES NOT LIKE THE
UNITED NATIONS.
WE'VE NEVER BEEN A FAN OF THIS
INSTITUTION.
IT IS A CORRUPT INSTITUTION.
WHY DOES THE WHITE HOUSE THINK
THIS IS A GOOD IDEA, SHE AND HER
QUESTIONING >> Shannon:
PRESIDENT TRUMP PULLED OUT OF
THE HUMAN BACK IN 2018 BECAUSE
AS YOU MENTION IN YOUR
INTRO IT INCLUDES CUBA AND
VENEZUELA AND RUSSIA AND
CHINA BUT DON'T FORGET WHEN WE
HAD A MEETING BETWEEN BIDEN
OFFICIALS IN ALASKA COME AT JUSR
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO THEY
THREW BLM IN OUR FACES AND SAID,
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
AMERICA THAT DON'T RESPECT THE
IDEA OF DEMOCRACY.
WHY WILL WE GIVE THESE COUNTRIES
MORE AMMUNITION VIA THE U.N. TO
COME AFTER US?
>> Jesse: IT'S LIKE HIRING A
PUBLICIST THAT HATES YOU.
>> Greg: HAVE BEEN THERE.
LET'S HAPPEN A LOT.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW
WHAT AMAZES ME, THEY ARE SAYING
ALL OF YOU PEOPLE WHO GOT YOUR
OWN PROBLEMS, YOU COME OUT OF
OUR SOIL.
YOU COME TO THE UNITED STATES
AND TELL US HOW BAD WE ARE.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO COMPILE
THE INFORMATION.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO REPORT
BACK TO THE WORLD.
HOW MANY WILL COMPILE THE
INFORMATION?
ARE THEY GOING TO GO INTO POLICE
DEPARTMENTS?
THIS HAS ALL STEMMING FROM
GEORGE FLOYD.
ONE OF THESE RAPID TOURS OR WHAT
IF THEY CALL ON HUMAN RIGHTS AND
THEY ARE TALKING NOW ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THE UNITED STATES IS
NOT REALLY MADE REPARATIONS
NOW.
I'M TELLING YOU THE END GAME IS
REPARATIONS.
AND INSTEAD OF TRASHING US AFTER
THEY COME ON OUR SOIL.
IF I WAS A POLICE DEPARTMENT I
WOULD GIVE THEM NO JURISDICTION,
NO AUTHORITY.
THAT IS IT, END OF THE GAME HERE
IT'S BEEN WITH THE DEMOCRATS
SPENT THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
JESSICA VOTE WHY DO WE NEED TO
BRING AN INSIDE CONSULTANT TO
GIVE US THE U.N. OPINION?
>> Jessica: I'M GLAD YOU WENT
TO THE IVORY TOWER SOURCE FOR
THE ANSWER.
I DO THINK THERE IS A TREMENDOUS
VALUE OF BEING PART OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
I REALIZE I MAY BE THE ONLY
GLOBALIST OR WHATEVER YOU SHOULD
SAY.
NO, NOT TODAY GREG.
>> JESSICA MY OWN THE EVIL.
I TRADEMARKED.
SHANNON BREAM.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT US.
IT IS ABOUT A COMMUNITY OF
COUNTRIES WORKING TO DO BETTER.
I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT.
AND WITH GEORGE FLOYD AND THE
REST OF THE WORLD FOLLOWING OUR
SUMMER OF PROTEST AND WHAT HAD
BEEN HAPPENING EVEN BEFORE THAT,
PEOPLE LIKE LAQUAN McDONALD
AND BREONNA TAYLOR, ET CETERA.
AND MANY AMERICANS AND THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS ARE
HORRIFIED BY THAT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE RISK
IS IN HAVING THIS GO ON WHILE WE
ALSO HAVE WHAT I THINK IS AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE WITHOUT
SUPPORT TO WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
CUBA.
THE FOCUS ON THE LANGUAGE OF YOU
CAN'T SAY SOCIALIST OR YOU CAN'T
SAY COMMUNIST.
EVERY PARTY GETS MAD AT THE
OTHER ONE WON'T SEE IT THE WAY
THEY WANT IT SAID.
>> YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THIS
RESPONSE IS OUT OF PROPORTION.
WHEN YOU MENTIONED THESE CASES
THAT ARE HORRIBLE, YOU KNOW THE
JUDGE BROUGHT UP THE PERCENTAGE
OF POLICE TRAGEDY.
IT IS INCONTESTABLE.
IT IS ALMOST CLOSE TO ZERO.
SO IT'S LIKE, HOW MUCH LONGER IS
THE UNITED STATES GOING TO HAVE
TO BE TOLD WE ARE OPPRESSED BY
SOME OF THE WORST COUNTRIES ON
THE PLANET JUST BECAUSE THEY SEE
THAT WE HAVE AN OPEN WOUND THAT
THEY CAN POUR SALT INTO?
THAT IS WHY WE GET UPSET.
WE ARE LIVING IN A TIME PEOPLE
ARE COMING UP AND GETTING FREE
SLACKS BECAUSE OUR MEDIA HAS
BASICALLY PAINTED US AS EVIL.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE SANCTION
IS TO PROSECUTE THE DEREK
CHAUVIN.
AND TO PUT A MONITOR OVER THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THIS ENGINE IS TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE DONE ALL THAT AND IT WE
HAVE BEEN TRANSPARENT ABOUT ALL
OF THAT.
WE DON'T NEED THIS GUY WITH
1 MILLION PEOPLE IN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS, THE
UIGHURS, TO TELL ME THE
UNITED STATES IS...
>> Greg: WE DO THE JUDGING,
RIGHT?
>> Jessica: I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH THAT AND I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD GET EQUAL PARTICIPATION
TO COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA AND
VENEZUELA.
I THINK THE HUMAN CAN GET PEPPER
ABOUT THAT...
-- GET TOUGHER ON THAT.
>> AND ESPECIALLY ISRAEL TALK
ABOUT PEOPLE LOSING THEIR SPOTS.
THE ONLY WESTERN DEMOCRATIC
ALLIES SITTING IN THE
MIDDLE EAST LIKE A SITTING DUCK
ALL THE TIME.
SO I THINK THERE IS A WAY THAT
WE CAN LOOK AT OURSELVES AND
GROW FROM THAT.
WE CAN POLICE THE POLICE THAT
NEED TO BE POLICED AND ALSO OPEN
UP OTHER COUNTRIES FOR
EXAMINATION.
ANGELA MERKEL WILL NOT COME AND
LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING ON IN
GERMANY.
THEY WILL LOOK AT THE U.K.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHO IS THEY,
CHINA?
>> Jessica: THE U.N.
OFFICIALS.
>> Jesse: IT IS A FREE ALL
EXPENSE PAID TRIP TO THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY WILL RUN UP A HUGE BILL.
AND THEN THEY WILL NOT DO
ANYTHING.
THEY WILL JUST SMEAR US HAS
RACIST AND PAT THEMSELVES ON THE
BACK AND JOE BIDEN GETS TO SAY
"SEE, WE ARE A RACIS